jeden der unsere anführer kadir auf
kritisiert werde ich mit dieser pistole
erschießen
da muss man schon feststellen dass
tschetschenische gruppierung mit
schwersten straftaten auftauchen wir
reden hier über leute die auch vom
stärksten waffen nicht zurückschrecken
das ist ganz schlimm dass diese leute
hier sind weil sie aufträge ausführen
sie sind mit dem regime also ängsten
verbund wenn ducati rufs regeln nicht
befolgt dann willst du der feind im
gefängnis haben sie mich dann am ersten
tag mit elektroschocks gefoltert
ein mensch gewöhnt sich an alles und ich
bin daran gewöhnt dass er mich jeden
moment töten kann